the presidential campaigns are targeting
key
battleground states a new poll shows
president trump
and democratic nominee joe biden are
tied in florida
the president went there yesterday biden
goes to michigan today
as paula reed reports mr trump also held
the kind of rally he used to have
before the pandemic
[Applause]
president trump addressing enthusiastic
supporters in north carolina
mocked the biden campaign for events
held in gymnasiums
where attendees observe social
distancing guidelines you ever see the
gyms with the circles
and escalated his attacks on biden's
running mate senator kamala harris
she could never be the first woman
president she could ever be
that would be an insult to our country
the president repeatedly tried to tie
biden and his record to china joe
biden's agenda is
made in china my agenda is made in the
usa
the biden campaign is rolling out a new
manufacturing policy proposal today
ahead of his trip to michigan
the policy includes a made in america
tax credit of 10 percent
for companies who bring overseas jobs
back to the u.s
or increase their domestic production
meanwhile the trump campaign is
reportedly facing a surprising cash
crunch
despite having raised over a billion
dollars since the president announced
his bid for re-election
president trump said tuesday he may even
be willing to contribute his own money
to the campaign whatever it takes we
have to win
after a record-breaking fundraising hall
in august
the biden campaign launched a fresh
start ad
tuesday donald trump failed joe biden
will get it done
which will run in key battleground
states this
is our chance to put the darkness of the
past four years behind us
in an unusual move last night the
justice department asked to take over
president trump's defense
in a defamation lawsuit brought by
advice columnist ejean carroll
she alleges president trump sexually
assaulted her years ago
but usually the president is only
defended by government lawyers when he's
sued for things related to his work as
president or things he does in his
official capacity
here the justice department argues that
the president was acting in his official
capacity
when he vehemently denied these
accusations last year
that is an unusual argument if it is
successful it could delay this trial
and it would leave taxpayers with a bill
for the president's defense
tony all right paula thank you very much